bon voilà on parle quoi on parle
également de car c'est fait la zara
c'est fait le deuxième people c'est fait
bon voilà le reste tout est fait
d'ailleurs les IP non juste pour vous
dire un mot ce que tu me dis pépé
Agatha je précise des petits trucs vous
n'avez pas vu pendant 2 semaines dans
TPMP bien sûr j'étais très fier parfois
j'étais Matthieu en été alors je me
prenais pour Madonna sauf que quand je
clique sur mon nom c'est plus Poutine
que Madonna j'ai tout lu que j'étais en
dépression nerveuse que j'étais en cuir
d'alcoolisme que tout j'ai lu suicider
il s'est suicidé fâché avec Cyril et
après ce qui est marrant c'est que tu as
les gens qui t'aiment bien et qui disent
non mais il va revenir et l'autre non
c'est un gros con et après entre eux ils
s'insulte pendant
il s'insulte sur un mec qui connaissent
pas d'un sujet qui connaît pas voilà
tout va très bien que Cyril j'ai parlé
hier
je vais beaucoup de choses en ce moment
juste pour vous dire je ne critique
aucun des chroniqueurs de TPMP c'est
juste qu'on a pas tous la même vie
Gilles et les excellente TPMP mais il
est chroniqueur c'est à dire Seb le
matin et pour son petit déjeuner il va
promener son chien il s'occupe de sa
femme moi j'ai trois vis je me lève le
matin je fais du sport j'ai deux
sociétés de production et quand j'arrive
à TPMP c'est ma troisième vie et c'est
vrai que je peux pas tout le temps tout
faire et c'est vrai qu'il y a des petits
soucis personnels à côté mais genre je
parle pas plus parce que c'est de la
famille donc il y a un moment on peut
pas tout faire et comme moi j'aime Cyril
que quand je suis là je suis très bien
payé je donne à 100% quand je peux pas
donner 100%, je le fais pas et je vais
vous dire quelque chose je suis payé
l'émission donc quand je viens pas je
suis pas payé donc rassurez-vous on
s'entend très bien avec Cyril et comme
ça c'est arrêter de vous engueuler et de
dire de la merde bah merci beaucoup
alors
[Applaudissements]